all right so once again I have not said
what what the movie grandeur the real
fonts is to rob and after the film that
we just watch I can't give it away yet
but it is also a Will Smith film so
let's talk about a bad one but not as
bad as we just saw let's talk about
Independence Day what's to talk about
what's to talk about especially with the
sequel having come out and everyone so
shocked and how bad it was well yeah I
don't know why that was a righteous kiss
I really can't believe that I just
thought you know these guys that made
you know this movie where everything
blows up and then they just tried to
make it over and over again except worse
and worse and then they tried to do it
with the exact same people and plot
except half the people weren't there the
entertaining ones and it was boring I
just been really surprised me these
people that didn't even really make that
go to movie in the nine and Roland
Emmerich has been making such a string
of amazing fans amazing I mean um
Stargate to independence day' godzilla'
patriot oh we divide the best of his
films honestly wrecked by Joan I was
gonna say Stargate Independence Day and
then nothing cuz that's really been in
and of those two I actually like
Stargate more yeah I'm sorry more to
wait it's it's it's merciful it's dumb
but it's mercifully short um down so far
is about say felt sure can we release
when all the other one we just felt
short
um yes target as much as I pick out is
just like you said it may be Stargate is
to me what it depends day is to everyone
else it's like harmless stupid fun with
a scene about her Russell's kid killing
himself which what the fuck with that
but aside from that it's innocent arm
was fun I guess you could say the same
thing about Independence Day but it's
just so stupid uh it's except that his
Will Smith who is amazing if he's the
one great Will Smith and the models are
the two legitimately great fun things in
this movie and there is a fair amount of
them my money okay when I saw it
originally first half didn't really
bother me much
oh I look like I saw me all why did I
send my mother to gala boy none of their
barbecue I know Ryan cuz we're very
tolerant that idea we were fresh off of
mrs. Doubtfire I'm like oh it's that guy
it's Uncle Frank or Aunt Jack or
whichever one they were playing I know I
it was more just I'm like okay I'm like
this is alright it's not great but you
know it was cool to see the big ships
and then they blow up everything and I'm
like awesome I'm good we're done out and
then that meant it's gone
more movie um that's where it fell apart
for me cuz I'm like no you blew your
load too early you you you splurged your
explosion all over the screen and it was
great this was back in the day when you
would just build a model of the White
House or that Tower in LA whatever it is
it may give us a fuck about LA uh you
know or or Manhattan or whatever or the
Empire State Building and they actually
blew these the fuck yeah this is one of
last film Yahoo use we got it a ghost
busters where was just such some of the
shittiest effects you know like tearing
apart the city there and I'm like this
is back in the day when you would just
like again actually hook it up um so
yeah and after that I was just like I'm
done cuz there was nothing nothing in
the rest of that movie that could
compete like Will Smith had some good
lines like a you generally like I'm done
with the movie after Will Smith's shoots
that alien down yeah yeah that's welcome
to earth yeah well better that's our
call also get out is it roll The Fresh
Prince credits just like in the review
and the movie and then yeah and then
yeah survived so much actually I ended
right there just welcome to earth that's
what I call yeah welcome to earth cut to
the end credits a just nice walk all
close encounter Viet venture stinger I
that I probably like it alright that was
pretty decent movie but it just keeps
going and going in characters I don't
give a sh I'd give a shit about the
president's wife I guess a we had to do
what happens to the president's wife we
have to know what happens to Randy Quaid
yeah fucking hate Randy Quaid in that
movie and I don't hate Randy Quaid and
all
I loved him I loved him in Christmas
vacation but experiment and then you
know and then Bill Pullman with the
silly speeches but yes
mommy sleep today is our it's not just
been a American Independence Day it's
the world's and then we will not go
silent it's just I know it's not for you
no it wasn't for me I was too old and
jaded by the time that came out I was in
late hiding we were too cynical yeah I
was in late high school and I'm just
like this is just silly like this is
meant for ten-year-old Shanna and most
of the people I know who really like
that movie or about a young ten years
old when it came out so I think there's
something to I'll give this movie this
and I really do mean this kind of in the
highest compliment ah it really is just
an accommodation of everything that was
like just kind of 90s and fluff and
kinda stereotypes and Jeff golden beat
Jeff Goldblum Will Smith being Will
Smith baby mama my friend is when he
just quotes Jurassic Park must go fast
to go faster I'm like go faster I think
really well okay we're just doing aliens
we're like every alien you saw at that
time and I think with its kind of the
same thing honestly I kind of think
about Space Jam
I fucking hate Space Jam but it is very
interesting to see just how nineties it
is how an iconic target time it is and
that is kind of interesting now it
happens you wanna be resting watching it
was definitely one of those early I
don't wanna say viral marketing but big
marketing moment well the best marketing
where they see ever one of the best
because it did that tease it was I I
want to say it was like we were watching
the Superbowl was a Super Bowl yeah and
they blew up the White House and that's
all they show they show these ships
coming and then just suddenly the white
house blows up which we didn't see what
those kind of effects yet we didn't have
this CG we didn't have these game and
the movie like this had not really been
done around that time at least for years
and years and years we had the B movie
and we had eight years to still stuff is
utterly uh yeah this amazing looking
like the White House blows up and this
is back when movies had to explain that
and they had to do it well so that when
you saw the White House blob you would
say what led to this what movie is going
to have this where this is a scene and
it's gonna be good see we
one at a point yet where these movies
could happen and they just didn't give a
shit they could throw whatever crap they
want at you they had to actually try to
make good movies but when the CG
explosion literally and figuratively
happened suddenly it didn't care you
came to see the effects and the
characters astray yeah that's all
secondary so I think that was like the
first film the course or get like these
disaster films going where the
characters didn't matter
you finished yeah okay uh did oh no no I
was just gonna say it didn't it did its
job because we all wanted to see it we
all really did see it
that was a double-edged sword though
because they showed the best scene in
the movie and when that white house blew
up that's it I was out like and I was
kind of like oh what else could you
possibly do like I didn't even think far
enough to like oh they have to defeat
the aliens I almost would have been fine
if the aliens just took over um but no I
kind of liked the idea of like we'll see
it punches yelling welcome to earth you
roll the credit and then there's a part
two coming I actually would have been
okay if like there they were advertising
part two you know like if it just ends
with the world is destruction they're
all looking and they shake their heads
like we're gonna get these fuckers and
then roll the end credits like whoa I
totally won't see in the next what I try
one see resurgence is if that was the
sequel repurchased it just kind of goes
on forever and they ruin the desert and
I don't stop it and you're a shit about
me yeah I really I'm only into it for
Will Smith and I will say this I did
enjoy Will Smith and Jeff Goldblum
together I kind of like that bow that
they need brent Spiner explosion to
where he was in every film that you're
he was at this he was in like common on
TV was a Star Trek movie he was in like
out to sea I mean sound like he was
doing almost like a Paul Lynde thing
Reese's like hey we don't get many
people down here when he's apparently in
the sequel he didn't die but what I
heard brent Spiner was that was like how
I don't we have not seen a sequel by the
way I am so no intention none whatsoever
uh I just do not want it was like what
do you think you're gonna do a review
I'm like oh fuck this movie it's way too
late it's looks so boring and that's
what everybody's just in the boring
movies are hard to do some of the
reveals are so silly just like listen no
matter what you may have heard there is
no such thing as area 51 actually mr.
president
well I'm like it isn't me NSA's job
supposed to tell the president
everything that is the one person
president yeah I'm like how the hell did
he not know that and nobody when these
aliens were landing and everything said
you know that um area 51 thing maybe we
should look into that again just like no
God keep it quiet gotta keep us at night
until the president's like none of this
ever occurred well not only that he's a
fucking Air Force pilot you would think
that maybe he could have even flown
there I have a good hacker Jeff Goldblum
we'll find a way Taha we'll need to uh
give him a call
yes ah ah-choo gesundheit
Oh see this girl do you fucking do that
for comedy I don't know somebody said
that it's explained in one of the
deleted scenes is of it I'm like even
then I'm just like not somebody's like
well yeah it had something to do I guess
maybe like they found the technology you
know and I shouldn't brought this up
because the youtubes just could be the
comments are gonna be flooded with
people explaining in this but apparently
something that like is hard to find any
other things that don't make sense in
that yeah it's like they found they
reverse engineered alien technologies I
can figure out how to talk to with that
ship they caught and I I depress co I
find it highly questionable in a movie
like this I'm saying it doesn't make a
lot of logical sense and this movie was
founded on logic right see right ya know
I'm today as well it's gonna say is that
to its credit I can I can definitely see
how someone can like this film
especially if you grew up with it young
uh it's kind of also the same thought
for like the first three spider-man
movies it's like I get it you're not
supposed to kind of question a you're
supposed to just sort of have fun with
the ride honest if the characters were
more like Will Smith in this movie or
they had that charm and they had that
interests and he threw in hard icing
right would've way it isn't charming
right ah even go boom I would have
accepted just because he's Goldblum and
he's fun to laugh at and stuff like that
and now even he's laughing at and having
fun um but if they were like that I
legitimately thought this was finding
that question you know the physicals are
anything but it's just there I don't
know these stereotypes are just so not
drawing and so and then think that
they're trying and so you haven't seen
these characters yet haha I just don't
buy a million I just don't find most
really all that likable the more bland
than anything they're bland we see on
every film ever made but he gave it gave
us like you know the summer of Will
Smith so I kick start it then that was a
good ride for a little while ya know
there's a while or even even if he was
in a bad film he couldn't do wrong he
was just amazing yeah yeah the rap
albums and yeah he just was phenomenal
and yeah then there she was like it was
Shyamalan up to the role for my kid
yeah so um but you all int laugh there's
and there's something about again I can
kind of like because the word being
tossed around with it and again I get it
is like Americana
is kind of like you know mr. Smith goes
to Washington battles the aliens uh you
know I especially like when they're
flying in that jokester who you know is
just gonna die I mean he's just there to
die and he's doing him some pressure
yeah not my favorite my favorite scene I
just like piss myself laughing whatever
I see is when he's doing like the
Reverend talking stuff and all the
pilots are just I think they're just
shaking their heads like yeah yeah
that's just that's our jokester
and it just bad say I'm a guy thank ya
that guy yeah it just kills me every
single time so it's in that kind of way
where it's like it's kind of fun and the
dog making in and stuff I could see
somebody legitimately liking this like
hey lighten up
just have fun or someone like in like
this is so insane to the wall silly you
got a laugh at it it's not legitimately
good it's goofy good yeah so people try
to we know it's it's an amazing it
really were no it's a legitimate good
fellow oh it's not and I think you know
that it's good in the light
it's good in that guilty pleasure this
is kind of dumb way yeah and we
definitely have those movies uh III
always reference like the first Ninja
Turtles film IV which is so stupid but I
love it uh and I even loved the
emotional moments and stuff but it's
it's teenage mutant fucking ninja
directly dumb now the fucking version
would be the TMNT porn or yes um we had
reviewed that in the first Transformers
movie the Michael Bay one I'll admit I
legitimately think that's a fun movie
I'm glad you know but it is the dumbest
fucking thing ever put on film it is so
stupid I'm not gonna defend it oh I
think it's a lot of fun cuz I remember
like it was on if I don't know few
months ago and I was watching it and my
wife loves that movie when they when
they're a lot of people love that movie
yeah she was just like oh my god I'm so
psyched up so and I'm like have fun
honey I yea yeah care I I completely get
it i 100% understand watching it and I'm
watching independent scene there's
scenes where I'm like I'm kind of
laughing and I'm like I'm into this and
every single time something happens I'm
just like why don't I like this movie
I'm having fun right now in the moment
what happens and then it's always
somewhere in the second half I'm like as
soon as you see what you see the Statue
of Liberty on the ground you know doing
the play of the apes thing and it's just
sort of like oh wow because again we
never saw them this time there was
kindly there's loans that just kind of
and there's things in the second half
that I enjoy but it's just some about
the way it's all peace to get like I'm
like okay area 51 that's goofy that's
fun brent Spiner that's goofy that's fun
we uh you know they they go into the
ship they give it a call that's stupid
but that's goofy that's kind of fun the
the whole Bill Pullman speech would not
go quietly into the night like I'm like
okay that's ridiculous with the saluting
the presidents in us I love that one
soldiers are cool I think he's an army
actually detached yourself Oh your bands
goofy that's not every time I watch it
like I like these bits but then there's
something that I'll tell you where I
lose it I lose it like I I'm fucking
done with the movie cuz like all those
bits are funny I'm really done with it
when they try the nuke attack I'm like
fucking this movie grinds to
yeah that's Jeff go boom gives us whole
environmental bullshit to the Argonne
blah-de-blah kick a trash can I'm drunk
you know our good bars blown it up
anti-nuclear weapons then I'm like the
funny thing is I'm like decides to go
Korea yeah
I'm like I'm not a fan of like nuclear
weapons but I'm like this just brought
this movie to this 15 minute
standstill Noam as we know and then they
wouldn't do a fires i aha we did it and
it didn't work yeah good point of that
you could have shown a scene with them
firing a nuke and gotten through that in
literally 60 seconds on where the
president's wife is dying that's when
the aliens are trying to talk to them
and get gobos argument is so full of
shit so fucking stupid
ah we've got aliens attacking and we
found out that they basically want to
drain our plan of resources but you
can't fire nuclear weapons on them
because they're maybe fall it's like
dude what's your only other option yeah
and we're already like yeah eggs already
news it looks like they already went off
oh yeah I'm like yeah they've destroyed
every I'm like fuck yeah you can fire
the nuclear weapons if it doesn't work
once then you know if it does work maybe
that's your god and wholly forgot yeah
it was yeah I'm like this is not the
time to shoehorn some anti-nuke message
into a movie when you've got aliens when
you got giant calamari I already fucking
frying the planet this makes no fucking
sense it makes about as much sense as he
does in a Jurassic Ark he always plays
the environmental scientist who's like
theories are total bullshit
uh yeah cuz like half of why you said
Jurassic Park cat makes em actually
finds away yeah no I remember since I
cut this out of the review because I was
getting a little too long but like when
he was saying like you know oh no no you
can't bring them back like you did
condors or trying to do condors you know
dissect they have their chance at nature
selected them for extinction I'm like
what are we are we not nature are we not
coming any of this and condors did not
adapt to us apparently no we're
apparently we are outside of nature like
I dunno of nature and so it's like and
all these things where it's like he'd
like
why aren't you talking this make sense
but like 5 of them don't yeah I I don't
know I put that whole part of the movie
just did it drives me nuts cuz I'm like
guys ok if you want an anti-nuke
messages at I'm in a place but it not
only made no fuckin sense but it just
stopped the movie and its tracks and
it's always right there where I'm just
like and this is why this movie doesn't
work for me I'm like it was writing a
lot of goodwill then it slows down at
meanders is kind of dumb it's silly but
then it just stops there and I almost
just don't even want to watch the rest
of it trying to get through that slog
right in the middle there and and then
just yeah mommy's sleeping I just uh it
it tries too hard yeah there's this
here's the thing too I think all these
characters is I mean I think even people
that love this movie know their cliches
they're all stereotypes um but there is
kind of this I get I get why people like
that again it's kind of like I know you
can't say watch it but like what we saw
the Jim movie I was laughing my ass off
because of how all their stereotypes
were and everything but and it really
made me laugh if I was fun but I think
with this movie I feel like the
filmmakers legitimately thought you know
like they're bringing these good
character like these strong interesting
characters and here's why you like them
it we're the first ones doing it we're
not talking we're not talking about a
movie like Independence Day where it
kind of takes in it has a gem had its
chance and nature D selected it for
franchise evolution good for nature um
but yeah but there's something where
it's like it kind of the only thing that
kind of bugs me if you watch this movie
and get into how corny and fun the
characters are I get that it's when
people that I wouldn't I ride until that
point yeah it's like right not to that
point yeah yeah I really wonder what's
gonna happen to Randy Quaid I really
wonder what's gonna happen to Jeff
Goldblum and the the Jewish father and
the you know Will Smith and so when
they're just like I do I don't get
Amelie don't know I don't know it's like
either bad and they show a lot of bad
decisions gonna happen
cuz it's a bad disaster but what started
a bad disaster movies oh no no no no no
bad
long viral but that's the funny thing is
it's it's basically taking its cue from
bad 50 60 70 s aliens and disaster
movies so it's just recycling them which
is why when it does it in a fun way I
can kind of deal with it it's when it
slows down like that I'm like oh it's
like it gets too drunk on it so yeah
Independence Day drinks the kool-aid a
little too much um and I think that's
probably the problem it's like no now we
have to have a message it like his other
fucking films do from that point forward
like he got drunk on his own kool-aid
it's like no now this is important they
have to smoke something I'm like no it
does it it's bullshit just have fun with
it and when the movie does then I think
it's actually like fun it's like really
the difference between Independence Day
and Mars Attacks is really a slightly
comedic tone and budget yeah they hit
all of the same themes in the same
cliches and tropes and for the same
reason I like Mars Attacks I come out
you're the one I enjoy Mars Attacks like
I'm like it's stupid but it's the same
reason I like Independence Day except
Mars Attacks like the whole way through
knows it's dumb and Independence Day at
some point it's like no now we're gonna
be important now don't bother it's like
just just just just go and have your fun
and well you know like all the people
that work at like agree with you as soon
as you said you like Martha that they're
just like no how about hey at no point I
say you know what's a good movie Mars
Attacks that's the difference I just
said I like that's sitting here and
saying Mars Attacks is a good movie it's
definitely a guilty pleasure for me like
the soundtrack come on spy probably the
last early development it's um strong
powerful words yeah um so yeah if you
like this film I like I said there is no
part of me that's like what the hell's
wrong with you how can you liked it feel
100% get it which is hilarious because
that's what we get what's wrong with you
hugging you know like yes no no I
completely understand how people can
like this film and how it's goofy it's
fun it's mindless uh you know it for me
it's that I can't quite get into those
kind of characters and I
I get I get the Americana thing I get
getting into it it's just not my thing
you know it's like so cliched and corny
I I could if you just cut a half-hour
out of the movie it's just another death
I feel like that's where it started to
begin where I felt movies started
getting too long hmm like I'm what now
if you cut about a half hour out of this
room it would be faster better tighter
and I would enjoy the silliness more
because there'd be just just be shorter
yeah you can cut out some of the
characters too and stuff um but yeah
there's something about this kind of
stupid that I get why people like it and
it may respect I should like it there's
just something about there owes me a
little too much the wrong way and I
think it's because I didn't quite grow
up at the right age you know for for
like this time period I think if I was a
little younger well I've gotten into it
more and I would I be having fun
laughing at it I take it oh this I take
this one also a little more on faith
that it was trying to be a little spoofy
with what it was doing I don't think
ever could drank the kool-aid fully yet
I think I think Independence Day
represents the last of the ones where he
still realized that he was making a
giant b-movie and then after that I feel
like you just got more self-important
than these movies got longer and it was
really weird they get stupider the
longer they get so I so if I give it
that kind of credit like I think it's
really the last Emmerich film that's
watchable what I heard 2012 is like so
stupid it's a lot of fun but I haven't
seen it hi that's the one I didn't even
bother I've seen every other dumb one
and I I just by 2012 I'm I give up I
can't I just I can't do this I'm boy I'm
out I might check that one out cuz I
ever just amazing like they're so bad
you gotta check it out like funny
um but yeah so that's um I think there's
anything else about it to say it's like
I said totally understand if you like it
just it's not my kind of stoop huh ah uh
uh uh
bump up up up up a but you are
forgetting one key thing boomer boomer
we'll live checkmate
yes